you think a guy like Jim afford a grand
has a chance to make that Warriors team
[Music]
[Applause]
talked about Jeff Ledbetter and being
able to see him for a few years and so
he understands he broke a few things on
this one ankles one prior than other
whoops that's true I don't know what
else is there for some excitement and
they just got it off the fast break nice
tomahawk by Barnett get way up in there
his leaves have cut up to 12 after
trailing by 20 to Johnson he was
determined to get this shot off look
good is good Oh baby
pass the half-court line don't look at
it for that cadet that was gonna count
7760 to San Antonio better that this
season and again I thought look around
this place is
Oh
[Applause]
look a moment ago it's just a a great
pass it starts with makrooh and then the
finish
oh ma that's not necessarily bad Doug
you look good yeah I appreciate it keeps
on a beautiful thefrom Toscano Anderson
pal guy dropping it off it's off the
shoulder of derrickson turnover pore on
to behind the fat fancy move in Outland
with the finish that three by derrickson
no look at Mecca in vision by Mika put
it in the pocket set them to the line a
chance for a three-point play
it's the rebound in all in one motion
drops a little drop-off pass to Derek as
we knew as the the footwork and the
poise right here to take the bump and
put the ball in the bucket they're going
to play it Howard has scored 17 here in
the fourth
Lakers get a three with four seconds
left unbelievable a long time to make
this decision
broke it's trapped by cheery to the
baseline it up almost to him
[Music]
Norville pal they definitely practice
Ted will see this duck here shake courts
vision just throws it up there body slam
yeah it looked like something they
worked on for sure the hammer and the
big fella said nope not happening but
this has four four sterling that's what
she's supposed to do attack the Big O
and made the bucket with the finish
it drew long this is group by long that
is full-on curling in it is the Navy
spectre-2 defenders then laying it up
let's go home
leave it a speed that was a dangerous
rebound Evans up top spy lucky
take a look good smiling each go it up
it was a little behind though it started
with one hand finished it that's real
athletic yeah how much is
way you can relieve pressure listen
giant seems to be
[Music]
[Applause]
but for one he's been in the league for
so long I don't again I mean he's been
in the league for so long and just being
able to experience things still talking
so that's what I love a healthy Oh
shouldn't find a creep I love a healthy
rivalry that we have here have McCree
right there with an excellent live Vegas
Lonnie Walker in the free doing some
talking give me that nothing is simple
two three and two threes in a spot up to
a turnaround jump our hard-working
physical position lists versatile
incapacitated Ambani wise there's 1000
run right now or the Clippers as they've
built their lead from 3715 in that
and I was going to talk with the Finnish
watch how hard cake [ __ ] crows creates a
lane give it to where no one else can
get it really good job late help right
here you got it
meet that world and the benefit for the
player is you get paid NBA wage over
that stretch of 45 days as the Clippers
lighten up as Man 2 cap and le that time
on the alley-oop Siteman here on that
man
no-look and one hand flush finished have
a poor man's robbed annoyed you really
improved right his last couple of years
as a 3-point shooter but another vicious
dogs by the Clippers that one courtesy
of Nigel Hayes whose baselines Romania
Moussa knock down that three-pointer on
the other end that's backed up 5-1 good
ball moving again only to happen is he's
about there now probably knows
[Applause]
at eight was bumped here as well yeah by
the crooks on euro league teams and
Spain Italy Lithuania three so my
goodness maybe spiked at ducks
mr. Robinson look at this we'll grab and
go for RJ and throws it away
Palmer good contest Braz Dacus mix very
much alive it'll need a three but he'll
take one anyway
roll so he gets mr. Robertson to change
the angle a little bit on the screen
almost a club for those who are just now
joining us now shooting just 59% from
the field which of course sounds great
but if you're just now tuning in maybe
Sean McDowell white spins right passing
and then and once can adjust and have a
good feel for the game and just know how
to play without being coached with the
finish on the reverse and even when you
start thinking about who could
potentially be in the running in the
Western Conference if you assume most
teams switch my goodness Josh Reeves
interrupting the conversation with the
rumbling room and so there are so many
converging factors that ask for sale
gets swatted inside by Hall another
the Dante hall to the corner handle for
the corner three it does not fall
Washington ball gets it ahead right here
Thea what he does he jumps in the air
but he's not trying to foul to set him
up for the block Jen Boyd that he said
he bought those psyche Oh bye-bye
coaches want to see he made the right
play look at that exit made the right
read yes let that pass like a comic book
here's a raccoon look at that
anticipation and elevation from waters
to set up on Oahu come on shake green
looked like he wanted Elmore to bring it
up eventually get you too many way there
and that's why he's just island in the
sea little summer chemistry at their own
you go there and then do that perfect
path and under four minutes ago kappa
leaders need to make something happen on
both ends here waters to williams it for
the diverse you said that young man was
a
[Music]
the reverse from Williams Jalen Adams in
traffic lost it Hutchison ahead of the
pack can he save it he can and he winds
up to the hands of the coco some early
in the game prior the Boston Celtics had
Kara Lawson
Oh
upon's asses definite that that was the
show stop plunged by the Bulls here's
the replay as Mychal Mulder steps over
outside the line so he's in legal
guarding position
Alexander Walker couldn't finish blew it
steals it Alexander Walker
punches it home left hand
[Music]
there's the steal and the finish by
Alexander Walker we got some sass there
[Applause]
Reno reacting let's just watch what
happens here
good pressure by Martin but he's gonna
pull them back put them on the deck and
then eventually they're gonna get a tree
out of this mr. Martin you're gonna hear
about that later from your eyes and this
is the ensuing three off Dennis Lindsay
that is coming up at the end of this
frame Whitehead splits the D not able to
lay it in ferocious block from John
normal playing but man he came a long
way and this is what he doesn't know if
anybody seriously consider drafting him
I'll think anybody did getting
everyone's attention said this it's
never is good ensues easy the dude he's
dunking on a seven feet and he [ __ ] it
too this was a terrific defensive play
by number 18 he's got the full Boca and
minutes with the Bulls and Hornets
sherlyn leads by six second quarter
coming up from Cox pavillions three
seconds remaining deep three good if it
goes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but some late fireworks for Xiao Fang of
China in while Boston shooting 62% 67
from 3 as that goes in plus the foul try
to sector quarter for the Lakers they
could get anything to go and then they
get one off flat
it's an unbelievable second quarter for
the Warriors with a splash team and then
the catch one to let it go
follow-through look at all the way in
baby I love you
that's what MacLean said in terms of the
hesitation move beautifully by race
balding what a play but you see the
alley-oop coming here no weak side help
you Garrett able to get down a lane for
the
saw that one coming hard left bound
they're too late for the Percival poster
as you see I'm here for nine minutes of
summer league he had a knee to knee
collision and just out of an abundance
of caution sat out the rest nice Fremont
laughter's Porter went fast with me and
George arguing with each other and
entertaining ten minutes as I thought
there comes Jackson haze something every
game comes out of nowhere here two might
want to put a body on Jackson the haters
and Duncan Robinson has hit a bunch of
shots but those two guys have been
sensational Robinson go get a look here
did he go out on the back door
[Applause]
was still good it was amazing why
wouldn't it be good you can't do that in
college which is idiotic this is great
that is your end of practice raised
their second leading scorer
Duncan Robinson's their first with 26 he
gets stripped it's a four on three for
the pelicans
[Applause]
he's pretty good blue a shoe teen years
in Europe one of the great European
point starts four in the NBA and always
always a quarterback on the floor
a half-court magic miracle therefore the
Maverick see oh if he would have saved
it for half time I might have won a car
but he still got three points out of it
great way to end the period for Dallas
seven seconds to go needs it for the tie
[Applause]
look at us he's gonna find the open man
Tyler Harvey knocks it down
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content